♪
>> WITH WAY OVER 100
MISSILES SHOT IN, THEY
DIDN'T SHOOT ONE DOWN.
THE EQUIPMENT DIDN'T WORK
TOO WELL, THEIR EQUIPMENT.
EVERY SINGLE ONE HIT ITS
TARGET.
>> WE WERE NOT LOOKING FOR
WAR.
WE WANTED TO SEND A STRONG
MESSAGE THAT THEY NEEDED TO
STOP THE CHEMICAL WEAPONS
PROGRAM.
THAT MESSAGE WAS HEARD LOUD
AND CLEAR AROUND THE WORLD.
WE BELIEVE WE DEGRADED THEIR
ABILITY TO USE CHEMICAL
WEAPONS TO KILL PEOPLE.
>> Bret: SYRIA, REACTION
AROUND THE WORLD TO THE
STRIKES.
105 MISSILES, THE PRESIDENT
SAYING ALL HITTING THEIR
TARGETS.
NONE SHOT DOWN BY THE
RUSSIANS.
HERE'S THE BRITISH PRIME
MINISTER.
>> THIS IS NOT ABOUT
INTERVENING IN A CIVIL WAR
AND IT WAS NOT ABOUT REGIME
CHANGE.
IT WAS ABOUT LIMITED,
TARGETED AND EFFECTIVE
STRIKE THAT SOUGHT TO
ALLEVIATE THE HUMANITARIAN
SUFFERING OF THE SYRIAN
PEOPLE BY DEGRADING THE
SYRIAN REGIME'S CHEMICAL
WEAPONS CAPABILITY AND
DETERRING THEIR USE.
>> Bret: BACK WITH THE
PANEL.
CRITICS ON BOTH SIDES
OLIVIER, SOME SAYING IT
SHOULDN'T HAVE BEEN DONE IN
THE FIRST PLACE.
OTHERS SAY IT DIDN'T GO FAR
ENOUGH AND DIDN'T PUSH THE
BUTTONS THEY NEEDED TO PUSH.
>> ACCORDING TO THE PENTAGON
IF YOU TAKE THEIR ACCOUNT OF
THE STRIKE IT WAS TACTICALLY
SUCCESSFUL.
105 FOUND THEIR TARGETS.
THE QUESTION NOW BECOMES
WHAT HAPPENS TO THE
STRATEGY?
RIGHT NOW THE U.S. STRATEGY
IN SYRIA IS PRETTY MUDDY.
WE HAD SECRETARY OF STATE
TILLERSON EARLIER THIS YEAR
DESCRIBING?
EXPANSIVE TERMS EFFORT TO
ACHIEVE POLITICAL AND DEFEAT
ISIS.
WE HAD THE PRESIDENT SAYING
WE WERE GOING TO GET OUT OF
SYRIA AS SOON AS POSSIBLE
EVEN WHILE ACROSS TOWN THE
GENERAL RUNNING THE WAR
LAYING OUT THE REASON FOR
STAYING.
THEN WE HAD THE FRENCH
PRESIDENT SAYING MORE
RECENTLY YESTERDAY IN AN
INTERVIEW THAT HE HAD
CONVINCED PRESIDENT TRUMP TO
STAY IN FOR THE LONG TERM.
WHICH THE WHITE HOUSE THEN
CHARACTERIZED AS WELL THERE
IS NO TIMETABLE EXACTLY BUT
WE STILL WANT TO GET OUT.
THE QUESTION FOR ME RIGHT
NOW IS WHAT THE AMERICAN
STRATEGY IN SYRIA?
IS THIS A ONE-OFF.
IT WAS TACTICALLY SUCCESSFUL
BUT WHAT HAPPENS TO THE
STRATEGY NOW?
>> Bret: MOLLIE.
>> YOU ARE SEEING PRESSURE
FOR SOMETHING BIGGER.
INTERVENTIONISTS LEFT AND
RIGHT UPSET THIS WASN'T A
BIGGER STRIKE.
WISH MORE WAS HAPPENING
HERE.
I THINK THAT I READ THOMAS
LISTON PUT IT WELL HE CALLED
IT A GOLDILOCKS STRIKE.
NOT TOO COLD, NOT TOO HOT
BUT JUST RIGHT.
NOT TOO MUCH TO INVITE
AGGRESSION.
NOT TOO LITTLE TO INVITE
THEM TO USE CHEMICAL
WEAPONS.
AND THE INSTINCTS THAT TRUMP
HAD WHICH WERE TO STAY OUT
OF SYRIA, HE SEEMS TO STILL
BE PUSHING FOR AGAINST ALL
THIS CRITICISM WHO WANT HIM
TO GET MORE INVOLVED AND BE
MORE EMBROILED IN YET
ANOTHER MIDDLE EAST
CONFLICT.
THOSE INSTINCTS ARE PROBABLY
RIGHT THAT HE HAS.
>> PICK UP ON THE
PRESIDENT'S INSTINCTS WE
LEARNED TWO THINGS HERE.
ONE, WE HAVE KNOWN THAT HE
HAS BEEN CONTRADICTORY ABOUT
THIS AND CONFLICTED HIMSELF
ABOUT WHAT RESISTING, GOING
IN AND TALKING TWO WEEKS AGO
ABOUT GETTING OUT OF SYRIA.
BUT THEN RESPONDING TO THESE
PICTURES THAT WE SAW HERE ON
"SPECIAL REPORT" AGAIN AND
AGAIN.
THE PERSONAL CONNECTION, THE
EMOTIONAL CASE IS WHAT
CARRIES THE DAY IF YOU ARE
IN BRIEFING THIS PRESIDENT
SECOND, WE SAW THE PRESIDENT
WENT WITH HIS GENERALS AND
TIME AND AGAIN ON NATIONAL
SECURITY QUESTIONS THIS
PRESIDENT HAS BEEN IN THE
40-YARD LINE OF REPUBLICAN
NATIONAL SECURITY POLICY AND
WE SAW IT AGAIN.
HE WANTED TO GO BIGGER, THE
EMOTIONAL RESPONSE.
HE STUCK WITH WHAT THE
SECRETARY OF DEFENSE GENERAL
MATTIS WAS RECOMMENDING MORE
LIMITED, MORE RESTRICTED.
>> Bret: ALSO THAT SPEECH
WAS PRETTY COMPREHENSIVE.
IT WAS LAID OUT ON THE NIGHT
OF THE STRIKES.
IT KIND OF SAID WE'RE NOT IN
IT FOR THE LONG HAUL.
WE'RE NOT GOING TO BE THERE
FOREVER BUT THIS NEEDS TO
STOP, THESE CHEMICAL
WEAPONS.
THE QUESTION ABOUT THE
SANCTIONS AND WHETHER NIKKI
HALEY WAS OVER HER SKIS OR
WHETHER THERE WAS SOME
CONFLICTS ABOUT WHETHER THEY
WERE GOING FORWARD WITH MORE
SANCTIONS OR NOT, WHAT DO
YOU THINK ABOUT THAT.
>> IT'S RARE ACTUALLY TO
WHEN YOU ARE ROLLING OUT
ECONOMIC SANCTIONS YOU DON'T
WANT TO TELEGRAPH YOUR
MOVEMENT.
BY THIS POINT PROMINENT
RUSSIANS HAVE TO KNOW WHAT'S
COMING.
SHE DID GET A LITTLE BIT
OVER HER SKIS BUT IT'S --
WHAT STRUCK ME WAS IT IS
RARE TO ANNOUNCE THIS STUFF.
IT ALSO HIGHLIGHTED
SOMETHING WHICH IS A
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION, RUSSIA
POLICY, AND DONALD TRUMP'S
POLICY TOWARDS RUSSIA WHERE
THE ADMINISTRATION HAS BEEN
PRETTY TOUGH.
IF YOU LOOK AT ISSUE AFTER
ISSUE, JUST TAKE ONE,
PROVIDING LETHAL DEFENSIVE
AID TO THE UKRAINIANS.
SOMETHING THEY MIGHT
ESCALATE THE CONFLICT THERE.
HAS HE A BIG STEP.
>> Bret: FOCUS ON WHY THESE
SANCTIONS DIDN'T COME ON,
DOES IT HAVE TO DO WITH
RUSSIA.
NO LOOKING BACK AT WHAT HAS
ACTUALLY HAPPENED WITH
RUSSIA.
>> WHEN THERE ARE SO MANY
SANCTIONS PLACED ON
INDIVIDUALS OR CORPORATIONS
IN RUSSIA THAT DOESN'T GET A
LOT OF MEDIA COVERAGE.
WE HEAR THIS ABOUT SUPPOSED
COMPROMISE THAT IS BINDING
THE PRESIDENT.
WHEN HE DOES TAKE A HARDLINE
AGAINST THESE PEOPLE AND
NOT -- YOU CAN BE HARSH WITH
RUSSIA WITHOUT GOING TO WAR
WITH RUSSIA, TOO.
>> THIS IS OCCUPATIONAL
HAZARD OF BEING A TRUMP
CABINET MEMBER OR OFFICIAL.